♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW GAVIN NEWSOM,
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE
IN AN ALL OUT, FULL ON PANIC
AHEAD OF THE SEPTEMBER 14TH
RECALL RACE.
POLLS NOW SHOWING A RACE NECK
AND NECK, ON WHETHER TO RECALL
THE FAILED FAR LEFT GOVERNOR.
NOW, JUST LOOK AT HIS DISGUSTING
HEADLINE FROM THE
"L.A. TIMES," "LARRY ELDER IS
THE BLACKFACE OF WHITE SUPREMACY
YOU'VE BEEN WARNED."
THE "L.A. TIMES" PRINTED THAT.
HERE TO REACT, HE IS LEADING IN
THE POLLS, IN TERMS OF WHO WOULD
REPLACE GAVIN NEWSOM, IF
QUESTION ONE, HE IS RECALLED.
I SEE YOU SMILING.
WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS A LONG
TIME.
I AM SORRY, I AM GENUINELY COME
A TO FRIEND, SORRY THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH SOMETHING AS
EVIL AND HORRIFIC AND RACIST AS
THAT.
>> WELL, SEAN, THANK YOU FOR
THAT, BUT I ANTICIPATED THAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
THIS IS WHY A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T GO INTO POLITICS, BECAUSE
OF THE POLITICS OF PERSONAL
DESTRUCTION.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
"L.A. TIMES" HAS ATTACKED ME.
THERE IS ANOTHER WRITER THAT ALL
BUT CALLED ME A BLACK DAVID
DUKE.
I THE EVENT OF A POLITICIAN FOR
A LITTLE MORE THAN A MONTH AND
AT FIRST THEY TRIED TO KEEP ME
OFF THE BALLOT CLAIMING I DID
NOT TURN OVER FIVE YEARS OF
TAXES, ENDED UP SUING AND A
LEFT-WING JUDGE THAT ELDER WAS
RIGHT, THREW IT OUT AND PUT ME
BACK ON THE BALLOT, AND THEN I
WAS ACCUSED OF HATING WOMEN
BECAUSE I WROTE AN ARTICLE 21
YEARS AGO WHERE I CITED A STUDY
FROM THE LEFT-WING ANNENBERG
SCHOOL OF JOURNALISM THAT LOOKED
AT 25 QUESTIONS, ASK OF MEN AND
WOMEN, IF MEN KNEW MORE ABOUT
THOSE QUESTIONS AS DID WOMEN
COME AND I QUOTED A LEFT-WING
PROFESSOR WHO SAID THE REASON
WOMEN KNEW LESS IS BECAUSE THEY
GET
THEIR PRIMARY SOURCE FROM LOCAL
NEWS, AND SHE SAID WATCHING
LOCAL NEWS MAKES YOU
DUMBER," I DID NOT SAY THAT, SHE
DID, AND THEN I WAS ACCUSED OF
BRANDISHING A FIREARM AT A
FORMER GIRLFRIEND.
I WANT TO SAY RIGHT NOW, I HAVE
NEVER BRANDISHED A FIREARM,
LOADED OR UNLOADED, AT ANYBODY.
AS FOR THE REST OF THE
ALLEGATIONS SHE MADE, NOT GOING
TO DIGNIFY THEM BY GIVING THEM A
COMMENT.
AND NOW THIS ARTICLE FROM THE
"L.A. TIMES," YOU ARE RIGHT,
SEAN, THEY ARE SCARED TO DEATH.
THEY KNOW IF CALIFORNIA CAN
ELECT A CONSERVATIVE GOVERNOR
LIKE MYSELF, AND THEY CAN AND
THEY WILL COME ON
SEPTEMBER THE 14TH, THAT ANY
STATE CAN'T COME AND THEY'RE
DEATHLY AFRAID OF THIS.
I AM TOLD THAT
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN IS MORE
FEEBLE THAN JOE BIDEN, AND IF
SHE RETIRES AND BECOMES
INCAPACITATED, THEY ARE AFRAID
THAT I WILL APPOINT A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, AND THAT WOULD SHIFT
THE WHOLE BALANCE IN THE SENATE.
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS, IT IS
MADE A FOR THE DEMOCRATS, SO
JOE BIDEN HAS WEIGHED IN,
KAMALA HARRIS HAS WEIGHED IN,
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS CUT A
COMMERCIAL, RECORD ON CRIME,
HOMELESSNESS, RISING COST OF
LIVING, THE WAY HE SHUT DOWN THE
STATE WITHOUT PAYING ATTENTION
TO SCIENCE, ATTACKED, ATTACKED,
ATTACKED, AND SAID IT WAS DRIVEN
BY REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS ALL THEY'VE GOT.
>> Sean: ROLLING BLACKOUTS,
BROWN OUTS, WATER SHORTAGES,
PAYING FOR WATER, THE COVID
HYPOCRISY, AND I GUESS
GAVIN NEWSOM HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT VIEW OF WHAT FOREIGN
POLICY SHOULD BE AS HE PRAYS
JOE BIDEN THIS WEEK, WHICH I'M
SURE YOU YOU TOOK NOTE OF.
>> OH, SHORTED.
HE SAID HE IS PROUD OF WHAT
JOE BIDEN DID IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT IS A WINDOW INTO
GAVIN NEWSOM'S INCOMPETENCE.
YOU DID NOT MENTION THE END OF
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT COME HE
ALLOWED $30 BILLION THAT SHOULD
HAVE GONE TO UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA, GO TO CRIMINALS AND
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINALS, THE MAN
IS COMPLETELY INCOMPETENT
AND THAT IS WHY NEARLY
17 MILLION PEOPLE SIGNED A
PETITION, MAY BE A THIRD OF
THEM INDEPENDENTS AND DEMOCRATS
THAT VOTED FOR HIM TWO YEARS
EARLIER, THAT IS WHY I AM ASKING
PEOPLE TO GO TO
ElectedElder.com, HE HAS
ALREADY RAISED ABOUT
$50 MILLION, PRIMARILY FROM THE
TEACHERS UNION, THEY ARE AFRAID
OF ME BECAUSE I SUPPORT SCHOOL
CHOICE, THE PUBLIC SECTOR
UNIONS, HOLLYWOOD, AND BIG TECH.
>> Sean: YEAH, THEY ARE GOING
TO THROW A LOT OF MONEY AT YOU.
THIS JUST CROSSES SO MANY LINES
AND SUCH A DOUBLE STANDARD
AMONG, YOU KNOW, THE WOKE
SNOWFLAKES OUT THERE.
APPARENTLY YOU CAN SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND
IT'S FINE, EVEN IN THE
"L.A. TIMES."
IT'S DISGUSTING.
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH